hey this is just amazing as I like to
say you really can't write this stuff
Donald Trump's attorney or we think he
still may be his attorney Rudy Giuliani
butt-dialed a reporter and was overheard
talking about how he needs cash and
saying negative things about Joe and
hunter Biden now a butt-dial of course
for those uninitiated is when you have
your mobile phone in your pocket and it
unlocks and accidentally calls someone
and they pick up and they say hello
hello but they just hear whatever
conversation is taking place in the
background or wherever the caller is but
the best part is that this wasn't just
any but dial on October 16th Rudy
Giuliani butt-dialed a reporter for NBC
News named rich Shapiro Rudy had
actually spoken to Shapiro earlier the
same night so it might have been like a
redial of the most recent name or number
in the call log at 11:07 p.m. Rudy's
phone calls Shapiro's Shapiro was
sleeping it goes to voicemail and a
three-minute long voicemail is left now
often three minutes is the maximum
voicemail length before it automatically
stops recording that's at least the case
with the David Pakman show voicemail
number we have a lot of experience with
people calling and hitting that max and
then being cut off Rudy was talking to
someone else and he was talking about
needing cash you hear rudy say let's get
back to business
I got a I got to get you to get on
Bahrain Giuliani says at one point the
problem is we need some money there's
then 9 seconds of silence and then Rudy
Giuliani says we need a few hundred
thousand rudy during this but dial
voicemail refers to robber several times
that could be Robert mangas Robert
mangas is a lawyer who happens to be a
registered agent on the behalf of the
Turkish government Rudy used to work for
the same law firm until about a year ago
um also fascinatingly this isn't even
the first time that Rudy Giuliani has
butt-dialed the same reporter last time
it happened he was trash-talking the
Biden's
it was months ago and he had said in the
butt-dial things like Biden has been
trading in on
his public office since he was a senator
going on to say about hunter Biden when
he became vice president the kid decided
to go around the world and say hire me
because I'm Joe Biden's son and most
people wouldn't hire him because he had
a drug problem also saying his son
altogether made somewhere between five
and eight million a three million
transaction was laundered which is
illegal as we've referred to before this
is stupid Watergate
stupid Watergate there's stupidity and
incompetence are matched or exceeded
only by the trumpet's who are gullible
enough to think that everything is fine
and everything is normal I was thinking
you know people like to say who would
play Trump if a movie was made about
this administration would it be alec
baldwin or would it be somebody else if
you make a film about this
administration how do you do it in a way
that doesn't appear to be a comedy
particularly for people decades from now
who maybe don't hadn't lived through
what it is that we are living through
today why do i constantly have to double
check to see if I'm reading the onion or
a satirical news website when I read
about what it is that people associated
with this administration are doing how
is Rudy Giuliani anyone's lawyer never
mind
lawyer to the President of the United
States of America and what so took to be
serious for a moment here what we learn
from this butt-dial what we learn from
what this reporter heard in the
voicemail that was left is that the Rudy
Giuliani being involved with trying to
smear and go after the Biden stuff has
been going on for many many months we've
recently learned about this we recently
found out about the July 25 Ukraine
phone call which was just a few months
ago this has been going on at minimum
since the beginning of 2019 or close to
it if not 2018 or even earlier and the
only thing that I want to know is the
full extent of how deep Rudy Giuliani's
involvement goes because it is very
clear that he is up to his eyeballs in
this stuff and we
never know because no matter what
subpoenas Rudy Guiliani gets he may
ignore them if Democrats don't actually
enforce those subpoenas I hope we will
someday learn the full truth of it I'm
not optimistic that we will